[Music]
training a machine to look at a large
amount of uh Nana Teta data and point to
specific examples and say well I think
if a human comes in and tells me exactly
what that thing is I'll learn a lot
about the problem that I'm trying to
solve so this general notion of
carefully selecting which of those
examples you want to spend the money or
spend the time to get a human to go in
and provide the annotations for those
examples that's this idea of active
learning you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
deep learning methodologies like
supervised learning have been very
successful in training machines to make
predictions about the world but because
they're so dependent on large amounts of
human annotated data they've been
difficult to scale dr. Phil Bachman a
researcher at MSR Montreal would like to
change that and he's working to train
machines to collect sort and label their
own data so people don't have to today
dr. Bachman gives us an overview of the
machine learning landscape and tells us
why it's been so difficult to sort
through noise and get to useful
information he also talks about his
ongoing work on deep info max a novel
approach to cell supervised learning and
reveals what a conversation about ML
classification problems has to do with
Harrison Ford's face that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
bill bachmann welcome to the podcast hi
thanks for having me so as a researcher
at MSR Montreal you've got a lot going
on let's start macro and then get micro
and we'll start with a little phrase
that I like in your bio that says you
want to understand the ways in which
actionable information can be distilled
from raw data unpack it for us what big
problem or problems are you working on
what gets you up in the morning so I'd
say the key here is to sort of
understand the distinction between
information in general and let's say
information that might be useful so for
example if the images are coming from
the camera that you're using to pilot a
self-driving car then low-level sensor
noise probably doesn't provide you
useful information for deciding whether
to stop the car or whether to turn or
make other sorts of decisions that are
useful for driving so what I'm
interested in sort of this phrase
actionable information here it's
referring specifically to trying to
focus on getting our models to capture
the information content in the data that
we're looking at that is actually going
to be useful in the future for making
some sorts of decisions so if we're
training a model that's processing the
video data that's being used to drive
this car then perhaps we don't want to
waste the effort of the model on trying
to represent this low-level information
about small variations in pixel
intensity and we'd rather have the model
focus its capacity for representing
information on the information that
corresponds to sort of higher-level
structure in the image so things like
the presence or absence of a pedestrian
or another car in front of it so that's
kind of what I mean with this phrase
actionable information so this
distillation from raw data is on doing
learning from data that hasn't been
manually curated or that doesn't have a
lot of information injected into it by a
human who's doing the data collection
process so going back to a self-driving
car example I'd like to have a system
where we could
allow the computer just to watch
thousands of hours of video that's
captured from a bunch of cars driving
around then what I want to be able to do
is have a system that's just watching
all of that video and doesn't require
that much input from a person who's
pointing to the video and saying
specifically what's going to be
interesting or useful in the future so
this information that's going to be
useful for performing these types of
tasks that we want our model to do
eventually before we get specific give
us a short historical tour of the deep
learning methodologies as a level set
and then tell us why we need a
methodology for learning representations
from unlabeled data ok so in the context
of machine learning people often break
it down into three categories so there
will be supervised learning unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning
mmm-hmm and it's not always clear what
the distinction between the methods are
but supervised learning is sort of
what's had the most immediate success
and what's driving a lot of the deep
learning power technologies that are
being used for doing things like speech
recognition and phones are doing
automated question answering for chat
BOTS and stuff like that so supervised
learning refers to kind of a subset of
the techniques that people apply when
they have access to a large amount of
data and they have a specific type of
action that they want them auto to
perform when it processes that data and
what they do is they get a person to go
and label all the data and say okay well
this is the input to the model at this
point in time and given this input this
is what the model should output so
you're putting a lot of constraints on
what the model is doing and constructing
those constraints manually by having a
person looking at a set of a million
images and for each image they say oh
this is a cat this is a dog this is a
person this is a car so after having
done that for thousands of hours you now
have a large data set where you have a
bunch of different images and each of
those images has an associated tag and
so now the kind of techniques that we
work with and the optimization methods
that we use for training our models are
very effective at fitting really large
powerful models to large amounts of this
sort of annotated data so that's kind of
the traditional supervised learning but
the major downside there is that the
process of providing all of those
annotations
can be very expensive so that process of
supervised learning has a lot of issues
with scalability what we'd like to do
ideally is make use of a lot of that and
figure out what kinds of information is
actionable so finding the information
that seems like it will be useful for
making decisions so that's getting into
a contrast between supervised learning
and unsupervised learning then there's
also reinforcement learning which is a
slightly different set of techniques
where you actually allow a model to go
out and kind of perform experiments or
try to do things and then somehow it
receives feedback about the things that
it's doing that says oh what you just
did that was a good thing or that was a
bad thing and that it learns by kind of
a process of trial and error
that's a general idea of reinforcement
learning mm-hmm okay we mentioned two
flavors of this unsupervised and then
self supervised
is that another differentiation there so
the self supervised learning it's not a
completely different thing but it's a
sort of subset of those types of
techniques so the general idea behind
self supervised learning is that we try
to design procedures that will generate
little supervised learning problems for
a model to solve where the process of
generating those little supervised
learning problems is kind of automatic
and the hope here is that the kind of
procedurally generated supervised
learning problems that our little
algorithm is generating based on the
unlabeled data will force the model to
capture some useful information about
the structure of that data that will
allow it to answer more sort of human
oriented questions easier in the future
so just to clarify this concept of
procedurally generated supervised
learning problems one really simple
example would be that you could try to
train a model to have some understanding
of the statistical structure of visual
data by showing a model a bunch of
images but what you do is you take each
image and you split it into a left half
and a right half so now what you do is
you take your model and all the model is
allowed to see is the left half of the
image mm-hmm
and then you have another model that
sort of tries to form a representation
at the right half of the image and so
the model that looked at the left half
to the image you present it with
representations of the right halves of
like let's say 10,000 images one of
which is the image that it looked at so
it's kind of got like a partner that
it's looking for in this big bag of
encoded right halves of images and the
job of the encoder that's processing the
left half of the image is to be able to
look in that bag and pick out the right
half that actually corresponds to the
image that it originally came from so in
this case we're taking something that
looks like unsupervised learning but
instead here what we're doing is
treating it more like a supervised
learning problem so the model that looks
at the left half of the image its task
is to solve something that looks like
just a simple classification problem and
then making this like a 1,000 Way
classification problem the other thing
that comes to my mind is there's this
weird thing on the internet were like
Harrison Ford you see half of his face
and the other half of his face and
they're completely different but if you
put each halves together they wouldn't
look like Harrison Ford but together
with the different halves they look like
him so that would really trick the
machine I would think actually I
wouldn't be so confident about that yeah
the question that you're sort of
training the machine to answer is which
of these possible things do you think is
most likely associated with the thing
that you're currently looking at so
unless there was somebody else's right
face half that looked significantly more
Harrison Ford ish than his own right
face half then them all actually could
do pretty reasonably I'd expect unless
you have somebody who where it was like
this really strict dichotomous
separation of the halves of their face
like two-face from Batman or some right
maybe the model would fail they're like
standard realm of human variability I
think it would be okay oh that's good so
let's move ahead to the algorithms that
we're talking about here and you call
them learning algorithms and you've
described your goal for learning
algorithms in some intriguing ways you
want to train machines to go out and
fetch
for themselves and actively find out
about the world and you want to get the
machine to ask itself interesting
questions so it begins to build up its
own knowledge base tell us about these
learning algorithms for active learning
and what it takes to turn a machine into
an information seeking missile yeah so
this kind of overall objective there
that you've described is targeted at
kind of expanding the scope of which
parts of the problems that we're
currently trying to solve are solved by
the Machine rather than by a person who
is acting as a shepherd for the machine
or as a teacher or something along those
lines so right now the machine learning
component of most systems is a very
important part of the system but there's
a whole lot of human effort that
surrounds the production and use of
something like a practical image
classifier or a practical machine
translation system so that's one part of
the effort that's required for getting
an automated system out there in the
world so part of the process is just the
initial decision like the thing that we
want to do is machine translation here's
a way of formalizing that problem and
specifying it such that we can go out
and now perform another part of the
process of this other part of the
process is a data collection hmm so
you'd have to go out and you'd have to
explicitly collect a lot of data that is
relevant to the tasks that you're trying
to solve and then you have to take that
data and you maybe have to have somebody
curate it to make that data more
directly useful or more immediately
useful for the kinds of algorithms that
we tend to use right now so a lot of the
work that I want to do is about trying
to reduce the amount of human effort
that's required on those two fronts and
trying to get as much of those two parts
of the problem automated and built into
the models that were training so that we
don't have to go out and manually
annotate all the data talk to me about
the technical end of that you know our
listeners are pretty sophisticated and
you're talking about algorithms that are
training a machine to do something for
itself go a little deeper there okay
yeah I'll kind of jump into the learning
algorithms for active learning part
which I guess I actually completely
skipped over as I was answering
the question before so training a
machine to go out and collect its own
data and point to specific examples and
say well I think if a human comes in and
tells me exactly what that thing is I'll
learn a lot about the problem that I'm
trying to solve so this general notion
of carefully selecting which of those
examples you want to spend the money or
spend the time to get a human to go in
and provide the annotations for those
examples that's this idea of active
learning so rather than just assuming
that you have a huge batch of data and
all the data is labeled a lot of
practical problems are structured more
like you have a lot of unlabeled data
and you have to decide how to collect
data and apply labels to it so that you
can then train a model so to do this
efficiently is you take some of the data
you train a model and then you look at
what the model is doing and you try to
figure out where it's weak and where
it's strong and based on where it's weak
and where it's strong you use that to
try and decide how to go out and pick
other examples specifically so that you
can minimize the amount of data that you
have to collect and provide annotations
to such that you end up with a model
that makes good predictions at the end
so that's just active learning and
existing techniques for doing active
learning a lot of them revolve around
assumptions about what kind of
classifier or what kind of decision
function you're gonna train on that data
that you're collecting the labels for so
there might be assumptions that all of
the data already has some sort of fixed
representation and then you're gonna
feed that representation into a linear
classifier for example and if you make
that kind of assumption then there might
be very good heuristics for going out
and deciding which particular sets of
features you want to apply labels to so
you can minimize the uncertainty and
minimize the number of errors that's
made by this linear classifier but for
working with more complicated data or
working in scenarios where you also want
to learn a powerful representation of
the data at the same time that you're
collecting the data and applying labels
you might want to sort of transform this
process where you decide on what the
model is going to be and then you sit
down for weeks or years and come up with
a very clever heuristic for how to
collect data efficiently to make that
model succeed when it has a small amount
of labeled data and you'd like to
replace some of those more effort
intensive parts of the process
with a machine that can kind of train
itself to learn what kinds of data it's
going to need at the same time that
you're also training the model that's
making the prediction let's spend some
time talking about your current research
and there's a lot of flavors to it let's
start with what you're calling deep info
Max or di M but I want to point out too
that in addition to deep info max you
have augmented multiscale deep info max
RM dem spatio-temporal deep info max
deep graph info max there's a lot of
sort of offshoots I guess you might call
it so I'm going to go sort of free-range
here because you'll be able to give us a
better guided tour of the main idea and
all the offshoots better than I will
tell us about the deep info max research
family and what you're up to
ok so the kind of higher level idea that
ties these things together is the idea
that we want to learn to represent the
data that we're looking at so sometimes
that data might be text sometimes it
might be images or in the case for
example of the deep graph info max it
might be a graph so the overall higher
level idea of deep info Max is that we
want to form representations that act a
little bit like an associative memory
kind of going back to what I was saying
about the thing with the split faces
before we can think of the left half of
a face and right half of a face sort of
as random variables so you can think of
just sampling the left half of a face
and there might be slightly different
versions of the right half of that face
that are all sort of valid so looking at
the left half I guess as you're getting
at with the Harrison Ford thing the
right half isn't always perfectly
determined but you can think of the
distribution of all possible right half
faces and the variability there is much
broader than the variability that you
have if you're just looking at what is
the right half of Harrison Ford's
face given that we're looking at the
left half so the mutual information
between our representation of the left
half of the face and the right half of
the face is high when our ability to
predict what the right half of the face
looks like is very good relative to how
well we could predict what the right
half of the face looks like in the case
where we didn't get to see the left half
if we were just looking at a bunch of
different images that had the same shape
as the images of the right halves of a
face these images have a lot of
variability in their structure like some
of them it might be the back half or the
front half of a car or something like
that and it looks very different from
faces so in principle we can sort of
make a reasonable prediction for example
of whether or not the image that we're
looking at right now and cause the right
half of the face but there's still some
uncertainty there and then when we add
in the left half of Harrison Ford's face
and we're trying to say okay well out of
the distribution of things that look
like the right halves of faces which
ones correspond to Harrison Ford the
more precisely we can make that guess
the higher the mutual information is
between our representation of the left
half and the right half of the face well
let me ask you to go a little deeper on
the technical side of this you've sent
me a slide that has a lot of algorithmic
explanation of deep info max and then
how you kind of take that further with
augmented multiscale deep info max so
the actual mutual information aspect is
sort of formally the way it shows up
here is that we sample this kind of true
pair of corresponding image and audio
sample and then we have a distribution
from which we can sample just another
random audio sample and we can sample
maybe say a thousand of those other
random audio samples and we can encode
them with our audio encoder and then we
can sort of present a little
classification problem to the model that
looked at the image where that
classification problem is telling the
model that looked at the image to
identify which among let's say 1,001
audio recordings is the audio recording
that comes from that same point in time
so the mutual information here what
we're doing kind of more technically as
we're constructing a
lower bound on the mutual information
between the random variables
corresponding to the representation of
the image and the representation of the
audio modality so what we first draw a
sample from the Joint Distribution of
the representations of those two
modalities and then we also have to
sample a lot of samples from what's
called the marginal distribution of that
second random variable which is the
representations of the audio modality so
we draw say a thousand samples from that
marginal distribution we construct this
little classification problem where the
model is trying to identify which of the
audio samples was the sample from the
true Joint Distribution over
audio and visual data and which of the
samples just came from random samples
from the marginal distribution so this
is a technique called noise contrastive
estimation that's been developed and
applied in a lot of different scenarios
so a good example of this is techniques
that have been used for training or
vectors but in the case where we're
using it it's a technique that can be
used for constructing kind of a formally
correct lower bound on the mutual
information between these two random
variables and one of which corresponds
to you know samples of visual data and
one of which corresponds to samples of
audio data and the Joint Distribution
over those two kind of random variables
is constructed by just going around the
world with a camera and a microphone and
just taking little snippets of visual
and audio information from different
points in time and in different scenes
all right well as you described deep
info max and then you have augmented
multiscale deep info max you call that
improving deep info max based on some
limitations in the prior how would you
differentiate how the augmented
multiscale deep info max is better than
the original idea yeah so the original
idea depending on specifically how you
implement it has some significant
downsides in some sense the original
deep info max was just looking at a
single version of a single image and in
this case there's sort of an issue where
if you're just looking at this single
image and let's say encoding all of the
little patches in the image the way that
the original deep info max presentation
kind of goes is that you
take that image you encode each of the
patches and you also encode the whole
image and so here we're going to sort of
train the representation of the whole
image such that it can look at all of
these patches and say that oh those are
patches that came from my image so this
is a little bit like that idea of
associative memory but it's applied on
sort of a single input okay
so kind of procedurally how you do this
is that you would take an image you
would encode it you get representations
of all the little patches and you get a
representation of the whole image and
now you're going to construct a little
classification problem where you take a
thousand other images and you also
encode their patches and you sort of mix
them into a bucket with all the patches
from the original image that you compete
at a full image encoding for and the job
of the full image encoding is to look in
that bucket and essentially pick out all
the patches that are part of its image
hmm so one of the difficulties here or
like one of the shortcomings of that
particular way of formulating it if you
take that more restrictive
interpretation the main downside is that
the encoder that's processing the full
image can basically just memorize the
content that's there and it's fairly
easy for the model to just copy that
information into the representation of
the whole image and essentially it's
just a memory that stores the
representations of all the little
patches there might be scenarios in
which is this is useful but for some
types of predictive tasks it might not
be so useful because you're not really
asking the representation of the whole
image to answer sort of interesting
predictive problems about what kinds of
other things might you see that we're
explicitly in the image that you're
looking at now so if you're looking at
left half of faces and right half of
faces if instead of looking at left half
of face and right half of face all you
did was you showed your encoder this
left half of the face you encoded it to
a small vector and then he showed it the
same left topic and and he said is this
the one that you looked at before the
model might not actually have to learn
that much to be able to solve that task
really well but if you take it and you
change it to a task where the kinds of
predictions that you're forcing that
representation to make are a little bit
more interesting you can ask a more
interesting question which is like did
this I come from the right half of the
face whose left half you looked at so
here now the model is answering kind of
a more challenging question
this is one of the main changes that we
make when we go from the original
formulation of the deep info max to this
augment to deep info max so this is the
Augmented part not the multi scale part
that's another thing we're looking at
multiple scales of representation but if
we just look at the Augmented part kind
of the big improvement there is that
we're forcing the model to answer
questions or form an associative memory
where the associations that we're
forcing it to make are more challenging
to make so that the model has to put a
little more effort into how it's going
to represent the data
[Music]
I'd like to explore consequences Phil
both intended and otherwise that new
technologies inevitably have on society
and this is the part of the podcast
where I always ask what can possibly go
wrong
so you're working in a lab that has a
stated aim of teaching machines to read
think and communicate like humans is
there anything about that that keeps you
up at night and if so what is it and
more importantly what are you doing to
address it so we do have a group here
that's working on what we call a
fairness accountability transparency and
ethics so it's a faith group so they're
working on a lot of questions that are
let's say immediately relevant as
opposed to questions that are kind of
long-term relevant or irrelevant depend
on your perspective so there's this idea
of existential risk which is more of a
long-term question so this is the kind
of question like well if we develop a
superhuman AI is it going to care about
us and take care of us or is it going to
consume us and its quest for more
resources so we'll set that aside and so
like the more immediately salient one is
the kinds of things that the faith group
is looking at and so these are things
like well if we're training a system
that's going to sit at a bank and
analyze people's credit history are
there historical trends in the data that
might be due to systemic discrimination
or systemic disadvantaging of particular
groups of people that are going to be
reflected in the data that we use to
train our system such that then when the
system goes to make decisions it's kind
of implicitly or accidentally
discriminating against these groups just
due to the fact that they were also
historically discriminated against and
that's reflected in the data that we're
using to train the system so me
personally a great thing that I could do
would be create something that's like
the internal combustion engine of
machine learning or even like the steam
engine those things have had an
incredible effect on society and that's
been very empowering and it's helped
with a lot of progress but it also
makes it easier for people to do bad
things at scale so I'm kind of more
worried about that type of problem and I
think that that type of problem isn't
necessarily a technological problem it's
a little bit more of a system or social
problem because I think the technology
is going to happen and so kind of the
things that worry me there are along the
lines of like seeing the technology and
the way in which increases people's
leverage over the world and ability to
affect it kind of at scale I guess for
me on a day to day basis like I don't
think about it too much as I'm doing
research because to me again it's not
really so much of a technical problem I
think it would be very hard to design
the technology so that it can't do bad
things well listen I happen to know you
didn't start out in Montreal so tell us
a little bit about yourself what got a
young Phil Bachman interested in
computer science and how did he land at
Microsoft Research in Montreal I kind of
already grew up with a computer in the
home I was fortunate in that sense that
I was always around computers and I
could use them for playing games and I
could do a little bit of programming and
I'm I'm not old but I'm not in the
youngest demographic that you would see
working in tech and one of the things I
really liked when I was in high school I
started playing a lot of these
first-person games where you kind of run
around any to shoot things you know for
better or worse it was fun so one of the
things that was a challenge at first for
me was I didn't have great internet so I
would do is go to the school library and
look around and it turned out that you
could download some bots that people had
made so you could sort of fake the
multiplayer kind of experience so I
thought that was really cool
and one of the things I had you know
started thinking about there was okay
well you know what is it that these bots
are actually doing so I've been doing a
little bit of coding and like making
some little simple games so thinking
about that like how would we automate
this little thing that kind of is fairly
simple at its core but that when we let
it loose in this environment so like
when we let it run around and compete
with the other players
it does something interesting and fun
and so that was sort of always at the
back of my mind a bit I guess
and I bounced around a little bit
academically and starting doing research
and
slightly different field but then
eventually I kind of sat around and
watched a bunch of online lectures and
there are a couple areas of machine
learning like reinforcement learning for
example that really started to click
with me and that I was excited about
because it was getting back to those
kinds of questions I'd asked myself
about before like how do we get this
little bot to do interesting things so
that brought me from Texas because I was
in grad school in Texas after having
done my undergraduate studies in New
York but then I found this group that
was in Montreal doing reinforcement
learning so I came and I worked with
that group and that's where I did my PhD
and then afterwards I hung around and I
liked the city pretty well and I was
looking around it kind of the jobs that
were available elsewhere and an exciting
opportunity popped up here so there was
a startup called maluma that was based
out of Waterloo and it was developing
kind of technology and software for
doing virtual personal assistants and
the company wanted to sort of start
getting more aggressive about pushing
their technology forward so they came to
Montreal because there was a lot of
machine learning cool stuff happening in
Montreal and then opened a research lab
and basically as those lab doors were
opening I walked in and join the company
and then about a year later we were
actually acquired by Microsoft so that's
how I ended up in MSR well at the risk
of heading into uncomfortable ice
breaker question territory Phil tell us
one interesting thing about yourself
that people might not know and how has
it influenced your career as their
researcher and even if it didn't tell us
something interesting about yourself
anyway personally I'd say one thing that
I've always enjoyed is being fairly
involved in at least one type of let's
say goal oriented physical activity this
is super weird sounding description but
for example as an undergrad I did a lot
of rock climbing so having that as a
thing where I could just really be
focused and apply myself to solving
problems in some sense a lot of climbing
is about kind of planning out what
you're gonna do and it's a little bit
like solving a puzzle sometimes and
having that is the thing that's sort of
separate from the work I do but that
still is kind of mentally and also
physically active and being able to kind
of
myself to that strongly I don't do the
rock climbing specifically anymore but
what I do now is I play a lot of soccer
so I really enjoy the combination of the
physical aspect as well as the mental
aspect of the game so there's a lot of
extemporaneous kind of inventive
thinking and it can be very satisfying
when you kind of do something that's
exactly right at exactly the right time
especially when you realize later that
you didn't really even think about it it
just sort of happened I guess that might
be related to some of the better moments
as a researcher that you have when
you're trying to solve a problem and
you're just kind of messing around and
then something just sort of clicks and
you just kind of see how you should do
it at the end of every podcast I give my
guests the proverbial last word so tell
our listeners from your perspective what
are the big challenges out there right
now in research directions that might
address them when we're talking about
machine learning research and what's
hype and what's hope and what's the
future I guess one that I would say is
filtering through all the different
things that people are writing and
saying and trying to figure out which
parts of what they're saying and seem
new but they're really just kind of a
rewording of some concept that you're
familiar with and you just kind of have
to rephrase it a little bit and then see
how it fits into your existing internal
framework and being able to use that
ability to figure out what's new and
what's different and figure out how it
differs from what people are trying
before and that allows you to be kind of
more precise and your guesses about what
is actually important but a lot of that
sort of washes out in the end and it
doesn't really survive that long sort of
at the beginning as a researcher you
have to you know rely on other people
because you don't really know where
you're going yet but over time taking
those training wheels off a little bit
and developing your own personal
internal framework for how you think
about problems so that when you get new
information you can kind of quickly
contextualize it and figure out which
are the new bits that are actually going
to change the way that you look at
things and which bits are sort of just a
different version of something that you
already have
Phil Bachman thanks for joining us for
Montreal today yeah thanks for having me
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Phil Bachman and
the latest research in machine learning
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]